hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play followed by Jeff
alright we you found a lantern wink and
now we're gonna make our way down into
the dark depths of hell something's
waiting for me down here I know it they
know it I know it you all know it oh
it's dark huh huh huh oh I'm not the GUP
oh not too good I I hate the goop ah let
me stand on the boxes boys martyr if
anyone knows me it's that I'm smart
ah God ah ah
okay piggies hello piggies dead peas oh
hello piggy sacks uh thing in here not
even a tinderbox ah tinderbox here not
for me any behind barrels huh a dead rat
that's phenomenal binder no okay
I'll do waste of time it's black seed
umm nothing there
oh it's dark gotta be careful about
using my lamp okay it's lighting here
all right what do we got woo what's down
there who lives like some goopy bits oh
that's that's um the stuff they use for
huh hey hey let me out of here
Oh your mistake ha ha ha ok that did
nothing ok mallet or hammer rather book
inkwell
sure I'll hammer out this walk I'm so
strong oh poor guy I don't know he may
have been a murdering bastard who knows
who knows these things
um oh this is blocks up doors so
probably way to get out get mash
oh so badass I don't even care
oh I'll live on e and o dark dark no
duck back dark dark okay Oh huh huh
uh was it nothing
yeah but dunya hey there you know a
million bottles dude I heard it pink or
oil ain't no ink
I needed a dark in there okay I like the
candle that's a little better
that's a little better okay I like that
nope no torch
oh it's dark so dark yeah did a little
more no more like Oh where's my dead
space Waypoint ah oh no that's a bad
memory pose that I know like up put yeah
oh oh oh boom so tough so great
here candle all right at least I'm being
better about using the tinderboxes a
little bit better I'm the best better a
little bitter batter better nada nanyem
not Danny numb oh yeah so far I can say
that this bond is indeed well-made oh
yeah yeah got a chair okay in a second
yeah oil old man they're doing a good
job of pumping up the psychological I
mean I haven't even seen a monster now
I'm already scared which is exactly how
it should be don't overuse monsters moms
when we finally move out
move I only take with me the three of my
most trusted servants uh-huh
William dead Andrew dead and dave also
dead we must not tell the others about
our secret mission vision otherwise they
will try to follow us we'll take the
secret passage to the exotic ass we just
not been visited for years now it's
located behind one of the shitty
creatures okay that's easy shelving
Olympus to discover the true meaning of
the great curse one of the most powerful
phenomenons in the world the power to
live forever
the power to avoid ever okay so um
something about the old library er I
don't know I wasn't really paying
attention
whatever I'll find it
ah ah like the Beast that guards the
hallways of the Gastel never stop
looking for their brain oh oh okay all
right
I wasn't scary yeah okay okay I can
buster how'd you get your head back no
go ahead go ahead
Wham hammer broke I'm so strong it's
ripped it apart
don't follow me bro Oh keep looking for
me it must be somewhere around here
okay whatever you say man
whatever you say hello bunny goodbye
bunny not down them oh you put the table
to put the job sure knocking okay
everybody
well okay I got a good amount of oil
anything behind here oh oh oh I thought
I'd like skipped like 10 steps ahead
oh man oh man that would have been great
if that excellent uh-uh no no oil
oh no no oil guy your chair okay don't
need a lamp pop up five down 14 up five
down 14 okay where the hell do I find
the machinery Wong up five down 14
I'll get out here doc try to stop me
nothing can stop me now can't stop me
move in never never gonna break my
stride a people we're okay so no power
do I give power I don't wanna go through
the door again oh hello where'd that
come from up five down 14 okay ed see
you and uh why not you and down you and
you and you and you I didn't get it oh
so close
um okay I gotta do up this down that a
five okay maybe just this one and then
the rest down that's probably it what no
aisle five down fourteen so to get
fourteen oh wait that was fifteen that I
had before
okay so oh yeah okay I got it I got it I
got it
this up that down this down and this up
yup there we go
oh I'm so smart oh man
Oh smartness juice everywhere hi how'd
you get unbroken what ha I miss ping ow
yeah yeah y'all all right back here and
then close the damn door
huh huh it's a it's a it's a it's a okay
okay good I'll get good yogi how there's
almost terrified me completely and the
only thing I've seen is like a little
glimpse of a monster just there it's
perfect that's ideal in a nominal you
look a bit nervous you look a bit
nervous I've heard stories about this
outside of the cast outside of the
castle well what kind of store the kind
of stories actually they're more like
rumors to store rumors a lot of folks
have said that NOLA has entered this
place for many years and they also say
that if you do you should be afraid and
why is that
oh because of that I got a talk with the
guys in AJ gave me because I I swear
that these guys are finished I swear
these are Finn's Oh
close the door well I don't know why do
you keep faking me out with all not oil
look the Astron Necronomicon I don't
know Oh didn't the box
okay okay um okay see what we got oh
okay just a vision I heard that a long
time ago
the castles old owners used to perform
their sacrificial rituals and after
their death the permanent presence of
evil has stayed flowing in the air
aha of evil till a13 that's why we need
to stay together I'm sure that the four
of us can and will remove any obstacles
will meet along our way to the old
castle dungeons yes sure
sure you will not really
oh man thought I heard something
okay so get down here huh huh huh who
what um I'm so tough Embree tough I'm
tough
hmm oh so brave I take all these guys on
I didn't have to be on my way very
quickly in the opposite direction okay
here we go it's in here close the door
always close the door behind you I like
it through what the hell
dr. boxes huh huh got my way box there
we go
I guess I can't get back um that's
bright enough in here build it hello um
budge so many doors don't wanna budge ah
no no too close Oh Oh No ah don't matter
less in between me and me pummeling
those monsters in the face hope I never
wanted this to happen
nah nah bodied it was not on the
internship what am i translating now we
just wanted the power to earn the power
to help those in need of help to help
those in need of help whyever it's not
wrong grammar it's just up
huh yeah you go on that side buddy while
I go over here yeah Gavin it uh Inc
I think ah oh no oh no no no no okay I
got a run get the ink get get get get
get get you all some more ink I see more
ink
okay you go over let me distract you
what was that
okay good enough
ah I get there you live in the town get
up get up yeah get up right there all
right
okay I gotta go in that little room over
there Oh
Abuk Dodge
I don't want to do in doing okay good
okay good lockdown them I don't know a
lot about him okay all right okay cool
buddy buddy buddy buddy okay
I guess I went oh what Oh what ah there
you go over there there you go and then
jump and then go do it oh I did it
was there a switch in that room that I
didn't see is there stupidly not
watching oh okay I got this okay okay
like I did forget this to do a switch
Zeus which I don't see you switch ah oh
don't come in here bro don't come in
here go
okay oh okay
where the heck am I going what am i
doing what am i doing what am i doing ah
all right Susie what the heck do I do
Oh up there oh oh I see I gotta go get
boxes put them up here
I put them up here and then put them up
here just like that
I love box stacking my favorite pastime
Oh God ah who's that oh it's dark in
here like oh I don't have my hammer
anymore
hello I have those greetings I am
getting sick of France's bossing us
around I can't understand how the others
can be so compared with the way he acts
that no-good arrogant bastard as we go
deeper in the hallways the water level
seems to be rising constantly we're
almost knee-deep in water the water
almost looks looks calm and clear it
actually looks very pretty almost
beautiful okay all right I gotta cut it
here but thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye